hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to through the portal
alright kliklak I'm just gonna know it's
not gonna hey there we go alright it's
like that lit it up again I like the
water effects spilling off of that very
cool inertia seeing as how the lyric and
care incarnated to the planet natural
evolution suggests we are unaffected by
the resin secreted from the mentioned
wildlife in large quantities there is a
mild euphoria but no other significant
results have occurred realm to the
quadrupeds of to when in contact with
lorrison immediately become enraged and
hostile the friend and foe alike due to
the dangers involved testing of subjects
and to is highly prohibited gram three
no specimens gathered from rome three
for testing consult the red nail up for
testing opportunities ram for the
subject of four are as of now the most
violently affected by the liaison when
the wreck contact occurs there appears
to be no effect but if a small amount of
the resin is ingested the victim
immediately becomes infatuated even
addicted to the supplier as if they
require more to survive when consumed in
larger quantities the substance ruptures
internal organs and bursts out of random
orifices in the head notably the jaw on
the top of the skull despite literally
not being an organic being anymore the
subject of realm four remain alert and
supportive of the resin supplier the
notes go on endlessly about realm 56 i
want to know about realm 56
mulata note this looks as if it has a
piece of a larger or article of orb
travel technology using this newly
discovered science we can learn
infinitely more about the universe in
which we live by instantaneously
traveling between dimensions with
minimal danger the discovery of the orbs
will forever change never seen history
interesting chain-of-command epoch
starting ends is 40 the red nailer has
been taken has taken blue nail as
position in recruitment for the spire
blue will be sorely missed and will
forever serve as a reminder that the
advancement of technology comes with a
price
Nayla so though some sorts are nailers
hi nella I barely know her oh shut up
all right what's this experimental
family the door is locked
spire archives I can like this it's my
voice a bit there's lots of stuff to
read so I can exercise my voice I get
the feeling that still is everything
nice and clear now I suppose boys
another tragedy
sounds like anyone you know is it baby
yeah that sounded like real Alexander
although I think he said that before
something's reading that someone who
tries to sound like
justine guardian's though not a threat
to any knowledgeable lunation it appears
all 20 orcs have individual Guardians
the guardians are sentient species of
the universe that absorb matter into
themselves reflecting online and
rendering them seemingly invisible
except here on inertia where the faint
red glimmer is visible interestingly
enough spires findings suggest the
guardians were created by a race that
existed long before us they are
certainly artificial non-organic
constructs that are supported by the orc
they are tied to as if the orb is a
power source eventually if any one
guardian is away from its respective orb
for too long it powers down and
disintegrates interesting I'm guessing
they're talking about the shadows
in spite of the amount of power
contained within these orbs we do not
understand enough about them to
comprehend the dangers that seem to
circulate through them well it is easy
enough to absorb each orbs protect her
in our own world every other realm
renders the guardians immortal this
proves that these mysterious or we were
born in this world alrighty then very
interesting I like this guy's attempt to
try to explain a lot of the history
involved and it was a way to go around
there
[Music]
um nothing on the shelves okay I didn't
see anything I don't see any here we go
do the recent events or business
regarding the spy on the orbs are
immediately canceled I will not put the
safety of guru nations in harm's way for
the mere experiments I regret the loss
of alien technology we will lose but
nothing places higher in my heart than
life the black Nayla so black nail it
seems like the sense of a leader among
them let me make sure there wasn't a
page I didn't think I didn't think so I
would have noticed the igloo purple it
glowed a pearpod
she here
I
I just love the amount of detail in this
world it's incredibly a real sincere
effortless take picked up Larrick resin
if I ingest that I turn into a monster
let's drink it down
slurp honking nope uh-uh ain't gonna
happen
I don't I don't think so they're like
you got to move on and I'm like I don't
think so all right what's this classroom
hello chair excuse me oh you know I'm
obligated to open every one of these gah
why you gotta be like that man makers I
know there's probably a goodie hidden in
one of these you're just giving me whoa
hello dead guy but he looks human
they're walking up and down the halls
I'm gonna have time now one of them
dropped the key out of this hellhole
prison but there's no way I can bring it
with me without them noticing it they
think looks so much like us it's so
different at the same time you know spy
had to even think about their appearance
they're coming I'm swallowing this key I
can keep it and have a chance John
listen I got to cut this guy open
being detected for learning oh okay this
is a classroom them there's got to be a
knife or something because it's
obviously in this guy's stomach gotta be
a knife I know when I gotta get my hands
dirty for this work and probably nothing
at ease and probably nothing wasting my
time
they know they know if they put desks
there I'm gonna look through all of them
head out and ow I know you're got
secrets give me your secrets well hello
oh I didn't see any it's up here
anything
I'm thing nothing nothing at all so what
do I do about this smells like wine or
some type of light alcohol oh oh so like
the wine that was in the wine that was
in the cellars open oh here we go one
more in this one is good too please
ignore us to go well okay then maybe if
I give him this oh wow ah no
whoa
what what the hell Wow okay alright a
standard key strange that these beings
would use a device made in our world all
right now I can go to the experimental
foundry I bet that guy's gonna get up
yep I bet he's gonna get up but he's
supposed to protect me I gave him the
rezoned I don't know I don't know
no know how this stuff work Oh oh my oh
I was wondering when a maza was gonna
Bob out wow that was quite an entrance
big guy oh hello
oh hi hi there are you doing I'm not
quite looking at you I don't think it
counts but I see you are you here to
protect me I doubt that very much
moving along ah I see a blonde one now
buddy Oh what you gonna do about it
oh nothing that's what I thought hahaha
okay yeah I didn't think so
get out here hard okay now I can go deep
wait ah here we go
yeah the experimental founder was over
here
click-click click-click interesting
the experimental foundry is whoa what
the hell huh Wow I see
oh hello you're in Oh
okay oh I'm not pulling those levers I
know what they do they opened the cages
this would be a bad idea to open them
would it not nice person hello kliklak
ugh is anyone else like exceptionally
impressed by what's going on gonna try
the yellow actually we try the red
because we feel I gotta like it hell
it's like no spitting sparks yeah this
might take a while to figure out
definitely powered oh hello okay we try
the peach color pink nope
whoa what the hell
what a pig pig come from into wristing
let's try the green yeah Oh
what uh hello hello alright then
environmental studies key very
intriguing
ah what the hell
holy crap don't do that don't want to do
that
ah walk dog there was something out
there wasn't there oh don't turn the
lights off after damn sure only crap Ola
its venture forward into the unknown
star shrubbery
this is so freaky
[Music]
Spira flights main entrance Wow look at
that it's like a field out there it's so
cool
something nearby power in a barrier that
blocks just maybe some lights actually
having lights oh oh oh oh oh oh oh no oh
no I done bad yeah Wow
what ha ha okay don't deviate from the
path that's for sure
okay how about we try the lights on
[Music]
ah the darkness like right in front of
me what the hell am I looking at what
the hell am I looking at
ah what the hell what the hell is that
oh my god like a dark shadow what the
hell is that
oh my was that you freaky as hell oh my
god I guess ah what's the thing it's a
real deal with the hell why darkness I'm
gonna be able to do that
holy crap ah oh man the first goes from
sorry I have everything that has new
monsters in it I don't even know what
that is
because I don't know what it looks like
so how can I tell ha ha damn [ __ ] good
oh my oh my oh it's a thing
hello a god damn it what is it it's
nothing and nothing nothing I'm gonna go
for the portal Oh
oh my what is that thing
Oh get out of my way please uh uh uh I
don't like that I don't like that at all
ah I was having happy fun times there
and the walls anyone throw that at me oh
my goodness ah man I don't know what
that was
ate this is cool though anyway man huh
anyway that's all the time I got for
this episode this is custom stories so
cool yeah anyway thank you all so much
for watching and as always we'll see you
in the next part
bye-bye